have you been keeping up to date with
the canadian truckers protest thing
oh yes uh not as much as other people
but most certainly the honking will
continue until freedom improves
so yeah i had this um
chapter in my book than you write that
says me magic is real
and i'm sure most people listening uh
have seen on social media that uh you
know in the last year or more certainly
there's been this meme of clown world
where people say something that's
perfectly ridiculous and they're
responded to with uh you know a green
clown
pressing his nose or there's another
meme where it's a lobster claw holding a
clown nose saying here you drop this
so that had been a thing and now
literally they're literally honking
and there's people on reddit having
meltdowns
uh saying like i can't sleep this is
terrorism yep uh and and you're exactly
right the honking will continue and the
thing that's i i've made this point
several times and i'll make it again
here uh especially with the british
audience
that um there is a misconception by
conservatives and i mean american
conservatives i don't know about tory
conservatives in the uk but that you
know you know in america especially
there's different groups
that the progressives latch on to to
further their agenda it's muslim
immigrants it's transgender bathrooms
one month or whatever so and so forth
and the point i always beat into their
heads is they don't really care about
these groups this is just whoever is a
useful tool at the moment and as soon as
that group is defiant in any way
they're thrown into the rubbish bin as
you'd say and the best example of this
is you know here we have the center-left
party is the democrats obviously there
you guys have the labor party but as
soon as labor
starts being defiant all of a sudden
they're nazis and it's just a
fascinating phenomenon to see and i
think it's just completely transparent
how
your measure or virtue as a an interest
group
is directly correlated to how useful you
are to furthering a certain agenda dude
that's so nailed it like but
isn't that also what
uh broke down the so-called red wall in
the last election that these districts
that had been uh read labor's read is uh
more correctly than here we have here
red is labor uh over in the uk these
were labor districts for i think almost
a century that went blue yeah and places
like hartlepool and blyth that are both
near me and where i've grown up they are
labor strongholds pit village my
granddaddy was a miner and he hated
thatcher and my daddy was a miner and he
hated thatcher
that ran on for a long time and then you
know the left appears to be
very much a sort of bourgeois foe
intellectual
this sort of middle class looking down
on the underclass and the working-class
movement at the moment and you're right
it's whoever's convenient this is what
bridget said the other day but she was
actually taking the shot
uh from a different angle talking about
people that are on the right who are
saying we care about women's rights
because of these uh trans people that
are encroaching on them she's like you
don't care about [ __ ] women's rights
right you're correct
you don't care about them at all it most
certainly goes both ways yeah it's just
like there's a certain
but there's a certain irony in calling
yourself labor
and then telling people that the unions
are nazis what is it in canada what's
the
any idea liberals right so they have the
the liberals uh which is the center left
party they have the conservatives which
is fairly recent because the progressive
conservatives had imploded in the 90s
and then they have a party to the left
which is what are the new democrats i
think they're called yeah and they're so
those are like
what's that the ndp yeah
so they're the real like hard leftists
or there's and there's also the green
party of course the trudeau has
disappeared like saddam did you see that
he's like he's gone
my understanding was he was on u.s soil
maybe
yeah i said that he should be if he's on
u.s soil they should send him to gitmo
but let's not forget that he has covered
so one of the problems that they've got
at the moment is that truckers 90 of
whom are vaccinated on
agreeing to a vaccine mandate about
crossing the border because presumably
america is concerned about people with
covert crossing the border and trudeau a
man who has covered has potentially fled
canada
uh due to security concerns about this
trucker's protest
into the us
well in his defense if you've got a
convoy full of nazi truckers as a black
man he's going to have to kind of
do a reverse underground railroad
they'll see his skin and they'll judge
him accordingly
yeah they got accused everything
happened right first off it was that
they were
actually everyone seemed to be kind of
behind it you know it's a peaceful
protest very polite and then as it
picked up speed and you realize that the
mainstream media was just going to start
throwing every ism and east that they
could first they said that they lied
there was the
canadian news outlet um
that's from new brunswick i think it was
where they're saying that
they're protesting their working
conditions so they just completely lied
about what they were protesting um then
a couple of days ago gofundme as i'm
sure people saw just decided to seize
all the money and said we're going to
send it wherever we want and that was a
huge backlash and they had they actually
refunded instead of seizing it oh is
that has that happened because i thought
that they seized it and said they were
giving it to particular worthy no no
it's been it's been resolved
it's because because they have something
called i think the issue was if i i
double check me because this is kind of
you see things on twitter it's kind of
like plato's cave but my understanding
was your people are going to call and
ask for chargebacks and when that
happens they're hit for each one with
like a 15 fee but also the public
shaming was enormous and i know some
politicians got involved
you don't get simply to just oh you know
i'm contributing to the trucker as well
that's null and voice so this is going
to go to you know
we want yeah yeah there's a quote here
organizers provided a clear distribution
plan for the initial 1 million this is
from
uh statement that was released earlier
this week and confirmed funds would be
used only for participants who travel to
ottawa to participate in a peaceful
protest given how the situation has
evolved no further funds will be
directly distributed to the freedom
convoy organizers we will work with
organizers to send all remaining funds
to credible and established charities
verified by gofundme all donors may
submit a request for a full refund until
february 19th so that was they were
giving people two weeks
to get on and order a refund but it
seems now because of the backlash that
they've just yeah done all of it which i
mean
it's strange that that somehow feels
like a victory
because the anchoring point has been set
so oh at least they didn't steal it and
give it to another charity when do they
shut it down and didn't give it to the
people it was supposed to go to
i would just i would say the victory
here
is that their machinations are made
public
because this permanently establishes the
brand as ideologically driven um it
would be one thing if they had said
disingenuously
that we're not giving this to the convoy
because it's the convoy is being run by
white supremacists and we stand against
white supremacists it would be a brazen
lie but that would be something that
would make sense this is just
they said well it's not organized it's
no longer classified uh by whom as a
peaceful protest is classified as an
insurrection therefore we can't take
part in insurrection great send the
money back um but i i think this is a
very healthy
and necessary
step forward in our cultural bifurcation
and there's one it's what's really funny
is there's an enormous movement that's
insisting that everyone takes sides and
this has been going on at least since
2015 and the sides are the good guys or
the nazis
and then there's plenty of people who
are saying
screw you i'm not with you and they
don't but we said if you don't side with
us your nazis like cool story bro um and
therefore they're forcing people
to view things uh as in group and out
group and that's causing the out group
to form alternative
mechanisms and then they're
pulling their hair out it's like how
dare you you're supposed to be in our
group as subordinates so this isn't
something that's going to happen
increasingly and it's something that
needs to happen uh and the idea that
there's one agency whoever it is who
gets to define
you know these riots are peaceful
and you know these truckers are
insurrectionists
uh and you know it's very clear
how the cards are going to fall i'm
shocked
to how quickly
people have grown
wise to how the game is played
because you don't have to have any
opinion on canada or the truckers
or really go fund me to know how this
movie plays out is it not more hatred of
the working class again though look at
these idiot uneducated truckers that
don't know what's best for them don't
worry you should be listening to us the
people who are actually in positions of
power the ones that are educated enough
to make decisions about you you know it
was okay for you to have your little
protest for a while but when it starts
to perhaps make genuine change
we are a lot less happy about that and
you think well hang on these
the working class that you're supposed
to represent they're telling you like
they're literally telling you people
aren't deciding to go out into the
middle of the canadian winter and it
looks [ __ ] miserable it looks so
miserable while whatever it is that
they're doing and people are setting up
pizza ovens and soup kitchens and
they're standing guard around a statue
of a one-legged man because it got
desecrated a couple of days ago they're
not doing that because they're bored but
that takes an awful lot of effort to go
and do something like that so this is
the working class telling you what they
feel
so no they're not so the argument is
they've all been brainwashed
by the forces of evil
somehow trump's probably involved so
they don't really recognize them as
having agency
when they're being defiant
and the issue with defiance is
now the entire population which had been
docile and submissive because they were
told and reiterated that they have no
choice that we have to make these hard
decisions in order to save everyone's
lives now to have a large group of
people say hold on a minute
there are other ways to go about this
this causes people who prefer safety to
liberty enormous psychological distress
because everything in their mental
makeup is about um giving up
choice and
having options in favor of being told
what to do for the sake of security and
safety which has not at all been
guaranteed to them whatsoever but they
can act as if it has been there's a guy
who called into a show that i listened
to saying that he hasn't had sleep in
nearly five days now because of this
honking and that's the other side of it
where you go okay like that bit does
suck i've been kept awake by loud noises
previously when i've been in cities and
it
really is quite bad
i don't really know what you're supposed
to do about that i i don't believe him
it's not because of the honking it's
because of his neurosis so what kova did
very effectively was to allow
highly educated
urban people which tend to correlate
very well with
mental illness such as anxiety and
depression and other sorts of neurosis
this gives them an external
source to blame for their issues so
instead of you know i'm suffering
because you know of me i'm suffering
because everyone's suffering
so
if you just because there is a cause for
something that does not mean that the
response is proportional or a direct uh
direct result of that cause uh i don't
believe it's not possible that sure i
i'll believe him that for five nights
his sleep was poor but you know it go i
i have very little sympathy for him yeah
and the thing is it's very important you
also remember that in this kind of
culture
being a victim is a high status marker
so the more you demonstrate that you
personally are suffering as a
consequence of bad people the more
virtuous they're accordingly you can
claim yourself to be if you enjoyed that
then press here for the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
subscribe peace